yeah like what would be the stakes
well it's gotta be uh it's gonna be
something that we can all participate in
floyd mayweather manny pacquiao too ooh
that's a great one front row
we're talking about look at that yeah by
the way by the way
yeah say whatever you want about me
being on my phone the entire time i have
the best [ __ ] video from that
of the last the lat them scoring a
touchdown yeah it's like
videotape that touchdown and then cut to
tominari ah
nice yeah no it's great that was a
really fun [ __ ] weekend that was
dude big that place is going that's
where larry the cable guy performs
oh my god [ __ ] does that performs in
places like that
that's how big his audiences are when's
floyd mayweather pacquiao i don't know
i think it's in december is it in
december yeah i think it's ten
tentatively yeah it's it's official yeah
i would definitely oh my god yeah
okay it might be in japan though what oh
yeah yeah
oh i'm [ __ ] so into this it might be
i haven't booked it yet so i don't know
there's just talk that it might be there
wow guys oh let's go to that in japan
damn that sounds crazy but also that's
like asking ari to cough up a hundred
grand
yeah we're not flying coach ari no way
not flying coach
hey you lost the bet
there's no way he could win right so
someone has to win someone has to win
but more importantly one person is going
to lose
so like if you beat me and i beat you
that don't mean [ __ ] cause we're all
beating ahri
right it's like a skins game right he's
already but you know he's gonna be like
i'm not doing the [ __ ] point maybe
but maybe he's listening to this right
now he's stewing
should we call him true he's getting
angry and he's sober which might bring
him stew even more right
he's like [ __ ] you i'm gonna win i'm
gonna [ __ ] win what if ari goes crazy
just [ __ ] goes whole hog every day
six hours a day takes spin classes and
crossfit
classes and wears it during jiu jitsu
floyd mayweather
is planning to come back in tokyo before
his rematch with manny pacquiao
oh this was a couple weeks ago so
oh so he wants a tune-up fight huh
that might not be real yeah it might not
be um yeah i'm
you know would you go to that you would
you go to the fight though yes it'd be
an interesting fight i mean they're both
past their prime but this will be a fun
event too yeah
i mean pacquiao just knocked out lucas
matisse
and floyd hasn't fought in a year since
he beat conor mcgregor
but that's not a real boxing i mean it's
a boxing match but it's on a boxing
match at an elite level like if it was
if he was boxing terence crawford or
someone who's like at the very top now
he's not in that kind of like zone
right now but he's still the best ever
or
if not the one of a handful of the
greatest boxers in the history of the
world
ever you know no question what we should
do is tear the
of the winnings okay first place pays
for nothing
whole weekend i like this idea second
place pays for their
pays for their ticket whatever's least
expensive pays for their ticket
and nothing else third place plays for
uh
all hotels or something you know like
tear it off so that the last place
just pays the most out but he's not he's
not dropping
right so fourth twenty let's say the
last place person
has to cover flights but they can use
their miles see the problem is
ari's bets are like no no the loser has
to wear
a beard of my pubes yeah and he's got a
he's got to clean his face with my comb
you guys scared me
all of this [ __ ] all of his
suggestions so psychotic
texting we have to drink all of our piss
and i was
liam saw that over my shoulder she goes
no no you're not drinking everyone's
piss
he said like one of he's like you got to
be a panhandler for six hours on the
corner
i'm into that already
[Laughter]
yeah he's yeah he wanted us to do really
ridiculous [ __ ] like
naked the tears of paying for it so it's
like not all
it's a good idea right so one person
doesn't take the whole beating
first place pays nothing all the way
that's true the first place should be
i don't cover [ __ ] the first place
should get like a belt we should make a
belt
sure sober october belt
a real one like a real real one yeah
like a wwe
october belt champ who's the champ yeah
jamie i need you this is a project i
need you to look up
where you would get a pro wrestling belt
and not no knock-off [ __ ] no no no nice
one oh my god i just got i beautiful i
just found my inner
voice when i work out that [ __ ] belt
just oh my god i'm in there i'm always
[ __ ] so excited
inner voice so you're going to start
doing two days
i might be doing three days wow look at
him look at him he's serious
he's excited now dude oh the i found out
now tell him he ain't [ __ ] and there's
no way he'll win this will you fire him
up even more yeah i know
tell me i can't run a marathon you
definitely ran a marathon
but there's no way you'll win this
though there's no way you'll win wow
tommy's got reverse psychology we could
get a pepsi belt
who the [ __ ] wants a pepsi belt i know a
guy he's diabetic so what
what what should we have
on the uh hey is that me up on the right
there i think it's uh
it is you oh no sorry the beard is the
bearded gentleman belt okay so we found
a company that makes belts what is the
name of this company
proambelts.com nice google customer okay
so we need
uh some sort of a logo we need like
sober october
is definitely the name of it right the
sober october belt
and um undisputed sober
champ yeah diamond champ oh yeah
what should we have on it this guy
should be our uh our face is engraved in
it
should it be like the like the no
smoking sign no boo sign
yeah no no pills on the side no needles
yeah no no no
and then a guy trying to suck his own
dick and we'll just tell everyone it's
yoga
yeah so we'll have to come up with how
long does it take to make one of these
belts
hopefully less than a month let's find
out
at least whoever pro am belts if you're
listening
three to four weeks oh we better get on
it we got to get on oh
so if we finish the design by the end of
this week we might be able to have it at
the end of the month you might be
holding up that belt hold up there how
does that feel
feels great i mean you definitely will
not be holding up i'll definitely see
the mirror joe
no wow there's no way flights lodging
tickets
this is missing you there's no way oh
i'm 4500
you've never worked out with them i've
worked out with them what happens oh he
gives up he's gotta
we have a workout together we've done
like hotel like pre-shows
we've worked out before yeah and we did
actually we went when we were in phoenix
we went to uh
like a mma gym oh that's right yeah
that's right we did we worked out
yeah tom and i used to go to uh
barry's boot camp together
what happened i i don't mind throwing up
if i work out
like i lie and then it seems like you
enjoy it i do because i
i know that i've done it as hard as i
can do it